mistakes mistakes mistakes your mistakes
mistakes mistakes mistakes mistakes
mistakes so many things go wrong when
you're starting a company and often I
think people ask you know what mistakes
should you avoid making and you know my
answer the question is don't even bother
trying to avoid mistakes because you're
going to make tons of mistakes right and
the the important thing is actually
learning quickly from whatever mistakes
you make and not giving up right and I
mean there are things every single year
of Facebook's existence that could have
killed us or made it so that it just
seemed like moving forward and making a
lot of progress just seemed intractable
but you just kind of bounce back and you
learn and nothing is impossible you just
have to kind of keep running through the
walls you see the difference in a school
teacher in an entrepreneur in school
that punish you for making mistakes yeah
entrepreneurs know you're not all learn
anything unless you make a mistake so
I've made so many mistakes I mean last
year I made a lot of mistakes but each
mistake I make I get smarter it's like
standing up and falling down standing up
and falling down it's like learning a
language you make a lot of mistakes it's
like riding a bicycle it's like flying a
plane make a lot of mistakes and
hopefully you live to it you don't have
to hold yourself hostage to who you used
to be or anything you ever used to do
cuz who has lived and hasn't made
mistakes when I think about my 20s and
what a foolish girl I was and how I
would give over my power to men who
really didn't mean me well but now I
hold no grudges against them either
because I realized I'm the one who gave
over the power because I didn't know any
better and now that I know better I know
I don't have to do that again
it's one of the most powerful lessons
any of us can ever know I've said for
years that that you have to celebrate
your victories and really celebrate your
mistakes and what I mean by that is that
you have to learn from the mistakes that
you make and you've got to create an
environment where people are not afraid
to take a risk and not afraid to do
things
are beyond what the expectations are at
the same time you got to set up a
framework for how those things are
managed and judged and evaluated and
while I was tumultuous in the early
career
I totally impetuous I have always had a
stammer so that's a weakness from the
beginning to the end I think that'll be
there I think I think if I if I go at it
I I made mistakes on deals
I don't openly admit it I'd walk around
talking about if I can make it this big
a dopey move anybody can make a move
don't be paralyzed I made lots of
mistakes on people I hired people in the
early days I had him almost always on
resumes and slickness which is probably
inversely proportional to talent so I
did a number of these things on a fairly
frequent basis but I talked about it I
think the thing is talking about what
you what you what your mistakes I helps
that organization enormously it allows
them to feel free to make it I mean I
bought an investment bank it Kidder
Peabody no one could make a mistake
thing in that booboo so we had we did
not have run it we had breakdowns in the
system we ended up on the front page of
The Wall Street Journal 17 times in 14
months right-hand column being called
dopes that's not fun and we went through
that because it was a cultural era that
I that I personally made and I owned up
to what talked to everybody about it I
needed people telling me no I needed
people to not get it and look at me
cross-eyed for me to really figure out
exactly what I was gonna do and how I
was gonna do it it's something I had to
learn as a woman in business is a to ask
for help
and to not be afraid of criticism and
and when you don't know what to do
to be okay with not knowing but learning
and also to not be defined by your
mistakes there's challenges there's
roadblocks there's mountains and you
just have to figure it out you just have
to be malleable you have to surround
yourself with really smart people and I
didn't think I was smart for a really
long time do you think you're smart now
yeah I think we agree you know I'm not
the smartest but but I try mistakes are
good things
mistakes are good things meaning if
they're made in learning in other words
so mistakes are how we learn because
mistakes produce pain and if you produce
that and you convert that to learning
like for example punishing people for
mistakes is bad because they hide things
where if you were to say to your kid and
they makes a mistake the only thing you
have to do was tell me what would you
have done different in the future and
then we'll be good that it learns makes
that a learning process or weaknesses
everybody has a weaknesses has a number
of weaknesses the great people that I've
seen in almost any area always have
weaknesses they just have known what
their weaknesses are and have ways of
getting around those weaknesses because
when we win we forget that there are a
lot of people who losing and those who
are losing their analyzing them think
they're trying to find out the reasons
for their loss the mistakes and if we do
nothing if we rest on low on our laurels
they'll come back after us next time and
I was on top of the world of chess for
20 years because I was very good even
relentless in challenging my own success
and did you go over all your games
absolutely once you succeeded no once
you failed absolutely yeah because even
the game we won always contained
mistakes in their courses it's
inevitable it's I can hardly imagine one
brutal and game with no mistakes which
means that on both sides
yeah one Bosa but the trick is noticing
when the other guy makes him is
absolutely yes if we won most likely is
because our ponent made their last
mistake but he made the last mistake
he's definitely liked the game and he'll
find what we did wrong in the previous
stage of the game so what is important
is to find it first and to make sure
that next time when he is trying to
access surprise although something will
be one step ahead
phallic honestly not do what is the
thing there to evoke honor
football was it they had okay Kansai TV
on g2 hard tonneau 2% solution welcome
where citizen jihad and it's a giveaway
Jesus Christ was at Pfizer had my my
Steve McQueen new tamoxifen today page
start a simple say - focus - iOS key
supposed to make you watch Avatar day
into the train for a train track give us
a call Seeger Eli focusing face my fate
I think we're gonna always learn from
other people's mistakes I mean being in
the public eye for so long I've I've
made a ton of mistakes and everybody
knows about him but I I don't look at I
look at my mistakes and any sort of
failure that I have gone through as a
lesson to be learned and I I worked
through it I was never lost
thank you guys so much for watching I'd
love to know which of the clips meant
the most to you had the biggest impact
leaving the comments below
and I'd also I'm curious what your
thoughts on mistakes are what are the
mistakes you've made in your business
are they good are they bad if they
helped you grow
share your thoughts leave in the
comments all during the discussion thank
you so much for watching continue to
believe and I'll see you soon